one use case is to use bigquery for
pre-processing on the training data so
the tensor flow or the machine learning
engine or ml ng itself is not suited for
the do the order of processing or
collecting all the data from enterprise
systems so you can use bigquery as a
data lag so you can gather all the data
coming from the enterprise application
server with server databases or it's
imported to the bigquery and do some
pre-processing on that then you can
output exported data as a training data
to the tensor flow or ml engine so let's
take a look at the actual demonstration
for that here I'd like to use the cloud
data lab to do to use the bigquery for
preparation or pre-processing and use
the chancellor floss to train your
neural network model for for machine
learning analytics so this is the sample
code I have prepared that is called
classifying Manhattan here we are
importing the bunch of the location data
from bigquery and training a neural
network model to classify whether each
location is Manhattan or not so we clear
all the cells first let's take a look at
what kind of determining data that we'll
be using
by executing this query so I'll be using
the another public data set called NYPD
collisions that because all the car
accidents happened in the New York City
we seized time staff and bottle latitude
and longitude but you cannot use the
disk role data as it is you have to do
pre-processing to that because you can
see that some roles doesn't have any bar
auditor
some roads doesn't have any latitude and
longitude that you we have to give
result
and useless garbage data so again you
can use the bigquery to do this kind of
the pre-processing and also I want to
have a new program if is Mahuta to do
have a flag the flag represents whether
the large student
longitude is inside my head turn on that
so this is the SQL I'd be using for
pre-processing and let me execute it and
also you can also execute another called
to extract the already data from
bigquery import it into the Python so
now you have all the data important
engine into Python code so as you can
see by using cloud data lab you can
seamlessly integrate the bigquery query
with the Python code you write and you
can continue use your psychic learn or
the numpy called running on big Larry
sorry about my voice so now we have the
training data set one is the is
Manhattan this could be used as a label
for training whether each location is in
Manhattan wanna and pairs of the wattage
and longitude for 10,000 rows so let's
do the feature scaling before starting
in training usually in machine learning
you have to clean the data out clean up
or cleansing of the data the one
important thing is to do is the feature
scaling and if you do the scaling and
plotting the data you can see the
training data set woodglue practice now
everything is centered on a zero but
still you can see the shape of the
Mahuta here and you can still you can
even see the Central Park inside the
data set so this will be the training
data set for neural network we will be
splitting the data into training data
and test data and use tensorflow to
define your neural network
here I'm using tensorflow especially so
called hi what is a high-level API of
tensorflow
and this is an one of the features we
have recently announced with 1001 at all
where you can just run a few lines of
Python code to define a neural networks
before that we have been using so called
low-level API where you have to define
all the computation graph a low-level
computation graph to define your your
neural networks
now you can just write a few lines of
course with spider so you can see we are
defining deep neural networks with the
four hidden layers and each hidden layer
has 20 nose so we have to hide in red
networks
let's check the recurrent accuracy of
the neural networks and how this neural
networks can classify the Mahuta with
that before doing the absolute training
so now you'll be seeing a map cross body
your network so this is the how neural
network thinks when the damaja is before
training so because because this is
before training the neural networks is
stupid enough still is to switch stupid
to classify Mahuta
physics this is the new Yamaha - so this
is where we have to train the neural
network model the accuracy is 75% so you
can write a for loop to repeat it we
call the feed method to train the model
by using the training data set so now
it's showing the gradually showing the
better accuracy so you are seeing that
twork model is trying to adjust how to
classify each data points to get better
result
so that network is getting much smarter
and smarter as you have so on the
playground demonstration yes it's
getting much much better so network
training is finished we got the
ninety-nine point eight percent accuracy
and now neural network is trying to the
split key Mahuta and blue queen with a
very sophisticated curve between them